[Música]
[Aplausos]
hace unos meses salí de una relación
dependiente
salir de una relación un poco tóxica
para mí y decidir no volverlo a ver
dejarlo a un lado olvidarme de él por
completo
él es mi celular inteligente es mi
iphone
soy millennial incluso iphone sí que
rara soy mi actual él es esté acá no se
ve
ese es mi actual y literalmente sólo
sirve para mandar mensajes hacer
llamadas y jugar serpiente si es que
algunos de ustedes conocen ese juego
todavía
y por qué tomé esta decisión porque fui
más feliz y hay datos que demuestran que
los jóvenes con un celular son más
infelices que no tienen celular y yo les
puedo asegurar que eso es verdad si soy
más feliz en un celular
y cómo sucedió todo esto todo sucedió
hace un par de meses como dije al
principio que mi celular mi iphone se
descompuso por cuarta vez
y decidí no volverlo a arreglar porque
al mes se iba a romper otra vez y no
quería comprar uno nuevo porque soy muy
cola
entonces empiezo a buscar uno usado y al
final ninguno me convenció sus dígitos
vamos a quedarnos sin celular a ver qué
pasa y así es como llegué a la
conclusión de no quiero usar celular soy
más feliz así
ha habido muchos cambios en mí todos han
sido buenos ha habido grandes y chicos
por ejemplo antes mira dormir a las diez
da igual pero por el simple hecho de
tener el celular a mano me quedaba horas
con la luz del celular reflejando me en
la cara sin hacer prácticamente nada
pero ya estaba en el celular y
obviamente al día siguiente me
despertaba cansada de mal humor ojeras
feas
y esto ya no me pasaban a veces sí
porque soy un poco floja pero sé que no
es la excusa el celular que me despierto
así
pero también ha habido cambios más
grandes volví a hacer cosas que dejé de
hacer al tener un celular cosas que me
gustaban
porque creí que era mi único
entretenimiento y me olvidé de lo que me
gustaba volvía a tomar fotos
no soy muy buena pero es algo que me
gusta y me apasiona y lo deje de hacer
porque jugué que el celular era mi único
entretenimiento y podrán decir bueno
pero puedes tomar fotos con un celular
da igual pero para mí no es igual la
sensación de tener una cámara en tus
manos esperar el momento perfecto
enfocar tomar mil fotos para que al
final escojas la mejor es todo un
trabajo diferente al tener un celular
donde puedes poner filtros o efectos
totalmente diferente
pero también me di cuenta de un cambio
que me impactó mucho que es el de las
redes sociales el tener acceso el tener
un celular a mano significa tener acceso
rápido y fácil a cualquier red social
redes sociales que todo el tiempo te
están juzgando que todo el tiempo te
están diciendo cómo debes de ser que te
des de poner con quién te des de llevar
cómo te debes ver tú eres 200 likes tú
eres 30 todo el tiempo te están juzgando
y no está bien no está padre pero asusta
más que con una red social todo el mundo
ya te puede localizar en cuestión de
segundos con el simple hecho de hacer
esto con tus dos deditos en un mapa se
puede localizar y pueden saber dónde
están y eso asusta y no está bien
como no tengo celular me he vuelto mucho
más observadora y no es broma me puedo
quedar en frente de un árbol parada en
frente del tronco voltearlo a ver y
decir guau esto es hermoso soy más
detallista y me fijo muy cañón en cada
cosa pero también me ha traído cosas
malas me he observado la cantidad de
gente que usa su celular porque estoy
segura que todos los que salieron en la
pausa ahorita sacaban su celular lo
primero que fue sacar el celular porque
es y estamos acostumbrados a eso y no
está bien está normal es molesto que
estés con una persona y que esté según
tú hablando con ella pero por el simple
hecho de tener el celular a mano no te
escuchan no te hacen caso no está bien
no está bien que te ignoren que tenga
segundo una plática pero te estén
ignorando no está padre y tú también lo
has hecho tú también has ignorado a
alguien porque estás en el celular y no
está bien
pero es peor cuando una persona está en
el celular
y deja que todo lo que está a su
alrededor siga sucediendo sea bueno o
malo
hace un par de años
mi mamá y yo tuvimos un accidente donde
nos atropellaron
y el momento y el impacto nunca lo voy a
olvidar yo recuerdo que estaba llorando
como loca llorando llorando llorando y
un dolor de la cabeza hasta los pies
nunca antes he experimentado horrible
pero específicamente mi pierna en mi
rodilla que me impedía caminar
estuve en células como
dos meses tres no me acuerdo bien pero
da igual el tiempo lo que importa es que
no estuvo bien lo que pasó la señora que
nos atropelló en vez de tener la mirada
al frente decidió que todo lo que
estuviera a su alrededor lo dejara pasar
y voltea ver a su celular y esa es la
razón por la que nos atropelló y yo no
quiero que a ninguno de ustedes espacios
o mi intención con esta plática no es
que ustedes cambian un celular como el
mío porque sé que no lo van a hacer o
que lo dejen por completo porque no se
puede en algún momento yo voy a tener
que regresar un celular normal porque es
lo que la sociedad actual pide pero yo
no quiero que ustedes se vuelvan
homofóbicos la definición de esta
palabra es miedo a salir de tu casa sin
tu celular
qué locura es esa yo no quiero que se
vuelvan dependientes del celular que se
vuelvan adictos y que digan no puedo
vivir sin mi celular me muero si no lo
tengo yo no quiero eso yo quiero que
sean más conscientes de su consumo al
celular y que vuelvan a tener una
plática con alguien sin la necesidad de
sacar el celular que nos olvidemos por
un momento que existe el celular papás
no contesten sus mails cuando sus hijos
les están pidiendo atención porque
crecemos como máquinas y en cuestión de
segundos vamos a hacer unos adolescentes
pubertos histéricos y se van a
arrepentir y nosotros jóvenes también
tenemos que guardar el celular cuando
estemos con nuestros papás abuelos tíos
amigos lo que sea porque la gente
también se va a ir en algún momento
aprendamos a vivir el momento a privados
aprendamos a vivir al presente
desconectamos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]